okay it's time for the mailbag I'm very
excited to introduce my dad dad welcome
to the show I am very grateful you
decided to have me answer ciao so let's
so we can we can jump right in the
mailbag lots of questions for you allow
people asking questions for my dad today
okay
McGuire asks dear mr. Shapiro what do
you think is the best lesson the
baseball can teach our society morally
socially and or politically thanks from
a huge fan while you give your answer to
that one that I have an answer for that
one as well
well we talked about this in the
beginning of the book in the end of our
book where week I talked about how
baseball moves at the speed of life
unlike the other sports there's no clock
that runs out at any time you don't know
what it's going to run out and so
because of that I think it teaches
patience and I think that's something
that sadly lacking in every way in the
political and in almost every sphere is
that people are in a rush and I'm my own
personal belief that that has stemmed
from a lack of faith in God yeah I mean
I tend to agree with my father so my
father speaks for me I'm but is it but I
tend to agree with my dad and all this
stuff which is why we get along really
well the only things that I would add as
far as baseball and its values for life
is not only the speed of the game but
also like most sports it's a meritocracy
so there's no affirmative action in
baseball if you're good at it you're
good at it if you're bad at it and you
don't make the majors and also there is
a bounce-back mentality unlike all the
most of the other sports it's played
daily so you lose one day you win the
next and that means that you'd better
get back up on your feet if something
bad happens and if you don't take that
lesson to heart you're going to have a
pretty miserable life ok here is another
question April asked hi Ben I have a
question for your dad what should we
tell our smart kids when they are being
bullied oh there are a lot of options
here one is obviously to try and fight
back but very often that's not the case
I hate bullying because I anything that
does not protect the innocence of
children I hate the innocence of
children is violated
so one is to fight actors in the movie
my bodyguard you know yeah it's a great
deal reality I ran out Adam Baldwin yeah
that's right great movie
the other is have your father intervene
as I have done yeah that's a that's a
really good story I think I've told that
story on the air for those who don't
know this story I was really badly
bullied in high school and I was two
years younger and I had my growth spurt
and yes pumpkins I actually am five nine
but this is when I was like five my but
I was actually five three these three
disorder okay so I was like as maybe
five foot one and I was maybe 100 and
1520 pounds and they're a bunch of
bigger kids who were picking on me and
physically hitting me bullying me and
it's pretty brutal and my dad actually
came into the administration would do
anything about it because it's a private
school and the kids parents were rich we
weren't as wealthy so they didn't want
actually do anything about it
so my dad called a meeting with the kids
and with the principals and actually
turn to the kids and said listen my son
is smaller than you but I am your size
and some of these kids are pretty big so
I'm your size and I'm willing to take
you out in the parking lot and I will
bite you one by one and I also have a
ball-peen hammer in the trunk of my car
and if you go down or not getting back
up and that was pretty much the end of
that particular problem yeah I said if
you ever touch a hair on his head again
you know you'd want to be looking behind
you yeah and with a like now have my own
two can't I feel like exactly what there
is where you can't do that where in some
cases where the school will not protect
the child in that case you need to find
another school for your child the school
is not going to do its job the school's
not going to protect your child that get
the child the heck out of there and find
some place where they will alrighty Gary
says hyman the mother has recently
informed me of my family heritage may
mainly do it in a sense I've no idea
accurate or how it affects my current
belief system I'm a Christian that has
accepted Christ as members and Phaedra
do I have an obligation to seek out what
this possible heritage link is is
ignorance bliss and religion so from a
Jewish perspective you do have an
obligation this one isn't really for my
dad but from a Jewish perspective you do
have an obligation to check out your
Jewish heritage because if you are if
you are Jewish technically than under
Judaism you are sill to it even if
you've accepted another religion so
according to Judaism and reclaim that
still Jewish you've no andrás converted
to Christianity you know from a general
non-jewish kind of secular perspective
is
country you can do whatever you want
from a moral perspective I always think
you should think to re-release in the
best possible way which is why you know
I've studied Christianity and why I've
looked at Buddhism and why I look at
Islam and why I think that it's
important to know a lot about other
religions so you know what you believe
and believe what you believe okay
Diana says question to Ben's dad what
did you guys talk about at the dinner
table when bed was 10 couldn't be
politics law policies or could it and
she's looking for some parenting advice
we talked about everything one of the
rules I had was it I never thought that
I had all the answers so I was you
remember I would ask friends of mine
were very intelligent people over would
they be over for dinner and I'd
encourage you to ask questions of them
because they were more expert in certain
areas I was although we talked about
everything we talked about politics we
talked about music classical music we
talked about sports a lot the this is
prior to an essential lesson I think and
that is that it is imperative that
parents take their child's questions
seriously I always took your questions
Siri and your sisters and your questions
seriously and I think that's vital I
think it's vital so the child feels
respected no matter what the question it
may seem silly to you but it's not silly
to them and I think that's really
important okay so here's another one
this is a wide mailbag question from an
annual papa Shapiro when did you realize
you had such a special kid invent I have
to read that visit ISM special when did
you realize that I was so awesome dad
well when you were three days old
actually numb because of all our
children were c-section babies you were
the first mommy came home when you were
three days old and they put we put you
on the table and you were staring up the
light and I said to mommy either he's
brain damaged sure he's a genius I'm not
sure which we still don't know yeah
jury's still out but there were certain
things that you were doing very early on
you're very articulate you're very
rational I told with vacuum cleaners
story sure okay
very quickly um my my wife was vacuuming
in one room
and then was about to and she called for
me David and I came in and and Bend was
standing on the vacuum cleaner and would
not get off and I said then if you don't
get off the vacuum cleaner it's going
break and if it breaks I don't know how
to fix it which means I'm gonna have to
hire somebody which means I'm gonna have
to pay them which means if I pay them I
won't have enough money to take us all
to Disneyland you understand the
consequences of all the things you're
what you're doing and how we won't be
able to go to Disneyland he was off in a
heartbeat and I realized at that point
that you were just rational that I could
be very rational with you my daughter is
even smarter than that she's doing the
same thing and I said the same thing to
her and she said just buy any back in
this once between daughters and sons
yeah exactly
Ricky said to Ben's dad what do you and
then have the most in common time now
this one also but you go ahead okay this
goes to something I was very important
to me and that is loyalty I'm sure
everybody knows this for people who
follow Ben but the bottom line is he's
very loyal very as I am to God to the
truth to America to the Jewish people to
his family it's about loyalty and never
backing off on that loyalty to me means
everything to all those things I mean
it's like truth justice the American Way
you know I mean is there anything better
than that no I mean you know God is
behind all that God has to be behind all
of that but truth justice and the
American Way being loyal to those things
yeah well I mean I think that we
basically have the same answer me you
can see my dad is very passionate guy
and that's where I got it so that's
definitely what we have mostly common
aside from our love for the White Sox oh
yeah which is definitely running high on
the list okay
david says david and ben i had my first
child on the way I know the intellect
was inherited as well as shape do you
have any recommendations for
intellectual stimulation of children
prior to formal schooling it seems like
you did fairly well with then yeah well
you know you I remember when you were
three we said on the driveway and I took
some chalk and you were drawing the
letters for the chalk so I could you
could learn the letters and you learned
to read very early very early on and I
think that was primarily I think that
was the primary thing that I focused on
was hoping learned to read and all you
and your sisters to learn reading is
everything reading is everything I mean
you know you took that that edits that
John John Quincy Adams was it John and
still John Quincy Adams yeah
never never never leave home without a
pole in your pocket right you know so
like poetry says so like I mean it's a
very funny thing we were sitting at
dinner one night recently and and I
there's a scene in Godfather Part 3
where where Michael Corleone a is he's
furious because he's trying to get out
of being in the mob and there's some
murders in he says they're dragging me
that has a very famously they're
dragging me back in and one that we're
sitting at dinner and then happened to
be reading a book and I said Ben nothing
then nothing
I turn to him I said you know this is
like Michael Corleone II with the you
know you and the books on you trying to
drag me into a conversation I'm reading
yeah yeah yeah I realize Aaron koenig am
because my daughter actually does the
exact thing she said she's just a
central focus really she will not be
central focus perhaps her mom nuts
so there's okay final question here from
Dakota how bad my question is for your
father and yourself
I've heard you mention in the past that
your family wasn't always Orthodox so
mr. Shapiro what were some of the
driving forces behind you deciding to
become Orthodox and bet how much of an
impact did that have on taking your
outlook on social life and your
political views so you first what made
our family Orthodox and then I'll talk
about how that sorry
that goes back to loyalty that goes back
to you know I feel incumbent as a Jew I
feel it's incumbent among me to be loyal
to all of my ancestors who kept this
enormous Lea important thing alive I owe
that to them they lived and died some of
them died in painful ways to keep this
alive and so when I was growing up I
even though I wasn't religious I looked
at Jews who were religious and I thought
okay they're doing it right I may not be
doing it but they're doing it right and
I want to get there someday
I want to be able to pay homage to my
ancestors and to God by doing it by
practicing Judaism authentically we're
practicing authentically and I think
that that's actually translated for me
in terms of I believe that people who
are Orthodox in Christianity or Orthodox
in Judaism or authentically you deeply
patriotic about the Constitution of the
United States
they're keeping alive a heritage
judeo-christian heritage that is vital
to keep alive and so orthodoxy for me
isn't every day every action I take is
supposed to be a living testament to the
God bequeathed us judeo-christian value
system that allowed a country like
America to rise to the top
the world and remain there and the
minute that we lose that and we lose
everything so I think that us living in
that way is what has allowed America to
become great and will allow America to
remain great and if you don't think it's
that great right now allow it to become
great again
yeah I used to say to all you guys
growing up there there's two phrases
that choose religious Jews useful to
take something's in kiddush Hashem
something's like oh oh Hashem kiddush
Hashem is something that sanctifies
God's name is Hillel ahem is something
that desecrates God's name and I said
remember every action you take you're
not always going to not not always do
right but every action you take is one
of those two things either sanctifying
God's name or your desecrating God's
name so be conscious of what you're
doing when you're out there well yeah I
love you and this is this is a book tour
buy a copy we didn't talk about the
words I wrote we need to talk about
those mats but if you want to read about
who I cook then you can read about the
white back here because there's
everything you would ever need to know
about the only season that matters in
human history 2005 when the White Sox
won the World Series book by me and my
pop and you can get that over at Daley
wire calm when you become an annual
subscribe you get a time by me or you
get amazon.com right now dad I love you
thanks for coming on the show
[Music]